something really interesting going on in
the YouTube space over the last week or
so you might know that for the last
couple of years there have been
struggles on YouTube that the david
pakman show channel has experienced the
first one was back in april of 2017
back then we were sort of a
middle-of-the-road sized channel and
we've also struggled more recently in
some other areas now we are sort of in
the top one or two percent of YouTube
and the struggles that we're having now
are pretty different from the ones that
we were having a couple of years ago as
a result of different algorithm
algorithmic and advertising related
changes to the platform and very often
whenever I talk about YouTube woes
people will write to me and they'll say
hey David you should unionize on YouTube
so that all of you channels could
bargain together with YouTube for
monetization and status and I've
actually spoken to entertainment lawyers
about this casually and typically what
they say is that YouTube is set up
legally in the United States in a way
that current law would not easily allow
a unionization of youtubers without
wholesale changes to the law regarding
independent contractors and employees
and a whole bunch of other things
however European law is different and
there is a huge movement in Europe for a
whole bunch of youtubers to unionize and
to bargain collectively for like rights
with YouTube so this is potentially huge
and I'm going to talk about it in detail
but before we even get into that I also
need to be very honest with you I don't
think I'd be interested in being a part
of this youtubers union at this point in
time based on our challenge size on our
channel size and I'll explain to you why
I support unions
I think collective bargaining is a great
way for individual players to get more
clout and have more control over their
circumstances I support teachers unions
I support factory workers unions and
transportation workers unionizing and
pilots sports league players the whole
thing but that being said right now
given that my channel is one of the you
know in the top one or two percent of
YouTube I don't believe it would be to
my advantage to get into a union
unless it's a union
of news and politics youtubers that are
my size are larger which are relatively
few and what I mean by that is now that
my channel is run as a part of a broader
business that is very different than
what it was even two years ago when we
had a couple hundred thousand
subscribers there is no way that a
consortium or a union of channels that
are not just news in politics that are
everything from makeup and gaming and
sports and whatever else and drastically
different sizes there's no way that it
would be to my advantage to be in that
Union because our needs and our
circumstances are now so different than
those of the majority of YouTube
channels now you might hear me say this
and react by saying oh David that's
because your channel is successful
that's that's why I mean I'm recognizing
that I'm not denying it I want the full
freedom to do or not do anything I want
on YouTube I want the freedom to put my
content or not on any other platform
that I want I am actually at the point
where only a union of the top news and
politics channels would actually be
useful and that would arguably defeat
the kind of egalitarian nature of the
Union to begin with because the truth is
that at this point even if YouTube
screws me I don't know that being part
of a union like the one in Europe would
benefit me this is why I left he whitey
Network years ago it had nothing to do
with conflict with TYT of any kind it
was just that I'm the most nimble and
free to do what's right for my channel
if I'm not affiliated with anything else
at a smaller size I might trade that
advantage for being part of the Union
right now it simply wouldn't make sense
but let's explore what they're doing
because this is serious this could
actually have a really major impact on
YouTube the youtubers Union Europe has
joined with IG Metall
which is Germany's largest Union and
Europe's largest trade union to launch
fair tube this is the most significant
YouTube related organization of labour
that we have ever seen here are their
demands monetize everyone bring back
monetization for smaller channels which
was taken away disabled the bots at
least verified partners have the right
to speak to a real person if you plan to
remove their channel transparent content
decisions open up the wrecked
communication between the censors and
the creators pay for the views stop
using demonetised channels as bait to
advertise monetize channels stop the
monetization as a whole if a video is in
line with your rules allow ads on an
even scale equal treatment for all
partners stop preferring some content
creators over others pay according to
delivered value spread out the ad money
over all youtubers based on audience
retention not on ads next to the content
and clarify the rules bring out clear
rules with clear examples about what's
okay and what isn't
the deadline for YouTube to respond is
August 23 so far no comment from YouTube
so this is really great but if you look
at the list of demands you will see that
it is all based on the connection
between ad dollars and content in the
same way that Obamacare did good things
but it also further ingrained the
for-profit health care system that we
have by giving tens of millions of new
customers to for-profit insurers the
demands that are being made here are
excellent obviously well-calibrated
demands that reinforce the status quo in
which content creators are given dollars
via people watching advertising funded
by advertisers buying an ad contract
with YouTube this is only a band-aid
this is not a cure for the disease half
of these demands would go away if we
completely reprogrammed how content
works if instead of having to make money
by having a video that advertisers say
meets their standards of what's okay so
that they will run an ad and give $1 to
YouTube from which the content creator
gets 40 cents or 50 cents or however
much it is this goes away which is why
I've been pushing for us to fund shows
we like directly period I am supportive
of this movement this particular Union
is not the right thing
for the David Pakman show at this point
in time but I wanted to succeed but the
real way to solve this is separate the
ad dollars from the content by funding
shows directly hundreds and hundreds of
you in the last couple of months have
said I understand the importance of that
and you've signed up for memberships for
example on our website wwhen pakman.com
that severs the tie between advertisers
and our content that is a very good
thing
hundreds of you have become patrons
donating as little as a dollar a month
to our show at patreon.com slash david
pakman show
I support the Union and I wish it wasn't
necessary by changing the system to one
where we fund directly the programs that
we want I hope you'll consider doing
that